la façade
[Applaudissements]
les toits
au total 28 cas va bien et il travaille
avec moi dans un instant il y aura le
sondage sur talent donc reste avec nous
tous c'est vrai donc allons vous on vous
le savez vous savez puisque j'ai plus de
basket dont j'ai plus de basket basket
et pourquoi j'ai pu de basket volley
peut être racontée
non alors franchement moi je alors
franchement il pleut des travaux c'est
pourquoi j'ai pu de base s'est passé
lorsque vous avez fait une très bonne
blague et ça serait bien que la france
ne soit pas au courant sur le génie
s'exprime comme froissement et halo
rédacteur en chef qui me parle dans
l'oreille qu'est ce qu'il me dit des
pelles des crimes dit haimoudi non faut
pas le dire
faut pas le dire bon alors mais
franchement c'est pas moi en plus on
peut il ya quelqu'un qui a fait je vois
pas pourquoi ce serait moi j'ai pas
besoin celui qui a ri en premier je l ai
déduit que né pouvait raconter mais
c'est que c'est pas moi je le dis bien
on va faire la chronique
oui je déciderai après si je raconte ou
pas pourquoi sa marque et la main on
commence avec le mode jour où il
m'accusait toujours c'est pas parce que
j'ai un peu plus basané que les autres
cette voie
[Applaudissements]
je vois pas mon jour mon préjugé coûté
très bien c'est toutefois aujourd'hui je
disais non je répondais non j'ai rien
entendu a cassé alors c'est pourquoi
vous pouvez le dire maintenant que j'ai
pas de baskets pourquoi j'ai des talons
alors non mais arrêtez pas ce que c'est
je sais pas il ya quelqu'un dans
l'équipe qui a fait quelques trucs
quelque chose à vos chaussures
elle me raconter quoi je voulais
raconter ce soir on peut le rencontrer
on est un petit port cas on est à nantes
sinon je vais la version courte mais
elle n'est pas cool quoi oui je peux la
raconter en mettant les formes
si vous voulez qu'il arrive je vous
demande juste quelque chose parce que
voilà quand même nom mais yat il ya la
présomption d'innocence dont quoi ce que
je sais que vous suspectez mais si je
dirais pas demain non je ne sais pas qui
a fait ça
la styliste matane et pour que je mette
une certaine marque de baskets ce soir
jeudi son fils de pompier gauche dans ma
basque et bien je sens que ça bloque je
me tiens j'ai pas dû enlever le papier
qu'on met dans les chaussures qu'on
achète donc j'enlève ce que je pensais
être le papier là je ressors mal à
l'aise avec quelque chose de marrons et
après vérification c'était de la banque
pour faire court quelqu'un je n'en mets
tiens cet actif
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas qui je ne sais pas
simplement je l'entendis tout mais
l'assuré tout bas je le vis très bien
mais je sais pas pourquoi je pense à 100
je pense pas vous mais c'est à dire que
le truc le plus humiliant c'est pas tant
d'avoir sorti mes doigts pleins de kaka
mais une belle merde
c'est que quand je suis revenu dans le
coup lors il y avait 45 personnes qui
rigolait et qui devait donc être au
courant depuis leur franchement alors je
vais vous dire vous inquiétez pas on
mènera cette nouvelle enquête et on
saura qui a commis son larcin très bien
là serons-nous donc la main